[Music]
yeah well we're also we're also supposed
to believe that uh
that dave portnoy has 4 million
followers when 250 000 follower alex
stein just [ __ ] [ __ ] reshoot him
to the [ __ ] to the core of the earth
yeah so where are all these followers
did he just like spend all his like uh
penn stock scam money on [ __ ]
followers i mean
i don't know how we could have penn
stock
it's down 52 since it launched
yeah that's that's good job dave one
like everybody knows the rules
you want to get into that let's get into
that [ __ ] yeah
that's [ __ ] it's
one like everybody knows the rules it's
patreon let's [ __ ] get into it um
so
this was dude and this was so late last
night
so this happened this happened during
real merch hours yeah yeah so i woke up
to this
um as soon as i saw it i was just
sending roy's stuff that's not going
to wake up to this
i'm like royce that sweet summer child
royce is just asleep right now i have no
idea having little dreams i had no idea
bark lightly barking in his sleeve and
kicking his legs having little donkey
dreams i'm like oh he's going to wake up
to some [ __ ] i [ __ ] hate this guy at
alextein 99 and will now actively root
for his demise well
what happened you may be asking there
was so many things in that [ __ ] tweet
oh you mean you mean besides the fact
the fact
the fact that it was retweeted by dan
crenshaw
you mean that the fact that dan crenshaw
retweeted it yeah
that's not a great uh
endorsement
uh
now so what's happening is i'm gonna go
back to the to the very very beginning
okay
of how this started so this started and
by the way portnoy made the mistake of
going into the dms with alex
you know
oh no
yeah and it wasn't good for him honestly
honestly because you know
so here's how it started
barstool tweeted this out
which was this is every man who spent
the weekend in vegas now this video i'm
sure a bunch of you have seen it
uh it was alex stein he went to a las
vegas city council meeting but he was
like disheveled like a disheveled
businessman right who'd lost it all in
the cathedral yeah very funny right it's
a good setup to begin with and it was
him pointing and i love that his
bitching was like he was bitching about
something that people go to vegas
he's like they feed you way too many
free drinks and they just let you gamble
with credit cards there's no way
there's no window there's no windows
there's no window so you don't know what
time of day it is
but it was funny because it was like it
was almost like like a six-year-old
child was in an adult man's body and it
never understood what vegas was before
it went like that was the premise of
this guy going like you just feed people
drinks and let them gamble what is this
place
so
here's what happened here's what
happened he also got [ __ ] thrown out
of there too the yeah i know that he got
joint out i have a story coming up in a
second where the city of la the city of
cal and that's the state of california
passed the law gavin newsom passed the
law to stop people from interrupting
city council meetings they're scared of
him
they're passing laws coming i knew it
was they're passing laws so anyway
this was the tweet the tweet was deleted
alex stein being alex stein
tweeted out it's so cute that barcelo
sports is owned by a stool president
tagging dave portnoy who is accused of
the most heinous things but they're too
afraid to keep my content up
now
you might be asking yourself
you might be asking yourself
what happened
well here's what happened
um
there's this bunch of tweets but it'll
be a lot easier if i put them but i'll
just tldr for you okay
dave portnoy had his guy who guy who
runs that the barstool twitter page
posts funny videos all the time right
and obviously that that video that likes
time video really there's no politics in
it's just on brand right it's on brand
for
that's what everyone goes through in
vegas right
well apparently the new sponsor which
deportnoy said it in a tweet
their new sponsor which is a betting
thing gave him gave barstool 500 million
dollars
to
ads for the year or whatever right
multi-year deal actually whatever what
because of that that advertiser reached
out to them and said you need to take
that video down and our agreement it
says you can't post any content that
makes gambling look addictive
which of course gambling is addictive
i'm not against it
i'm not i'm not again i'm not against
gambling
but um
let me see here
uh
[ __ ] all these people screaming at him
i [ __ ] hate this guy and i may hate
the stool sales guy more still sales
guy's the guy that posted the video i
[ __ ] hate this guy alex stein and
root for his demise
be more uh then it go then then called
this other guy calm down dude hate is a
strong word then dave portnoy called
this other guy a [ __ ]
uh oh so this is the alex stein crown
got it so it was anomaly saying was a
massive supporter of yours barstool and
your whole vibe during the pandemic tate
made you look like a massive feminist
beta and you're kind of a fence sitter
enjoy rooting for abortion and women
controlling you anomalies 100 right here
because what what what other people are
mentioning is
in the same week well two weeks in this
in the two-week period
not only did dave portnoy get cucked by
alex stein he got cut by andrew tate
andrew take him on his show and mr frat
boy i'm a frat boy titties frat boy
titties beers pizza frat boys diddy's
pierced pizza sports guy
got confronted by a dude this is kind of
the vibe right got confronted by a dude
who basically made it was saying oh no
you joke around about not liking women i
really don't like women right
and of course
dave dave portnoy
white knight
everyone was like man portnoy [ __ ]
tape made you look like a [ __ ] oh did
he start simping
hardcore
let me clarify why i hate alex stein i
hate losers who make everything
political on both sides a stool sales
guy posted his video without watching it
all it started going viral so gaz went
back and looked at it again and we
watched the full thing we saw the
gambling stuff
literally only thing we don't do is make
problem gambling jokes so he took it
down not a hard trade for 500 million i
don't even know who this clown was
that's a lie or that if it existed uh
until he tagged me in this [ __ ] getting
personal so yeah [ __ ] hate his guts
dave portnoy
is also mad and he also retweeted the
video that we played of alex stein you
know messing with the abortion
protesters yeah this guy anybody who
does this is a piece of [ __ ] i don't
care what side an issue you are you
conduct yourself like a piece of [ __ ] i
already apologize slightly to stool
sales guy for not researching it before
responding i'll never mention alex stein
again but here's something that you have
to understand alex stein and him started
getting into the dms dave portnoy
uh that that that you made from getting
children addicted online gambling
congratulations and just like that you
walked into a knockout punch by the way
there's no knockout punch here he got
pornograph ratio you're getting
humiliated on twitter tonight guess i'll
just have to sleep gently on my 500
million
you are a baby murderer you know that
in case you're wondering [ __ ] rules
now let's go even further into this
because this is not done yet okay let's
go even further into this
um alex stein started pointing out hey
why do you have to be in your tippy toes
when you take photos is it because
you're so short and that's an insecurity
of yours there's look at his feet he's
on his tippy toes oh my god so of course
now we're hurting him now we're getting
to his insecurities
now we are then these are just some
photoshops that i saw he was retweeting
this is funny
um then there's this one where they they
put his face on aoc
uh
then there's this one
then the height one then somebody
retweeted him as a karen calling the
police okay that's really funny
i didn't see some of these
that's what he's bragging about uh and
so then here it gets even better dave
portnoy come on my podcast tomorrow 100
i'd love to what time what's your email
then he gave him the email and then
guess what happened
as soon as he found out that he was that
alex i'll never talk about him again he
can't come on my show because i don't
have political people on my show is
what from my understanding what he said
and then alex stein of course said
champions don't run and hide dave
dave you ran and you're scared okay dave
but i'm pretty sure i'll continue to
live run free in your head for a while
after getting humiliated like this and
he did get humiliated he got [ __ ]
destroyed
destroyed uh then there was uh
him standing on his tippy toes to take
pictures oh this is one he retweeted
that i sent him
are you winning son i just retweeted
dave portnoy it's uh
dan crenshaw only verified account
that is defending dave portner because
remember he has no friends on the left
the only verified account that is
defending him is dan crenshaw retweeting
it
so now that's just because [ __ ] dan
crenshaw hates alex stein for being a
brave muhajdin warrior
you look very beautiful in that dress
you look very sexy
[Laughter]
listen
i rarely get left speechless
i was left speechless by that guy run
oh my god dude [ __ ] by the way liv's
a tick tock backing them up too like
everyone's backing up alex nobody is on
dave portnoy's side he would have people
on his side
if he the entire left didn't hate him
too but that's the problem with dave
portnoy and i and this is the problem
with fen sitters in general when you're
a fence sitter you get gored by both
sides and you end up with a pole up your
ass it's not fun so pick a side boy
because this isn't going to be
and some people have been calling
basically portnoy like it's called
barstool conservatism right
and that's what he is that that's what
portney is because he doesn't want to
make things political but he will go on
tucker's show and he'll go on fox news
show and he will definitely make things
political all the time oh yeah he'll
[ __ ] he'll be a little [ __ ] clout
goblin but
you know when it comes to you know
allowing other people to say their side
if it's all i'm not going to platform
you all right i'll be honest with you
man you know why it bumps me out because
i i like portnoy's videos i i don't i
don't we watch his pizza reviews all the
time you know i think he's a funny dude
but
this level of
lit whenever you hear somebody say look
we could talk about whatever we want
except then then you can't talk about
whatever you want no but you can't i
love free speech but i mean you know why
can't you make problem gambling jokes i
don't understand it we have a [ __ ] we
have a [ __ ] sponsor that supports
booking site and yeah [ __ ] gambling
can be very addictive and is a [ __ ]
problem for some people that's like
that's like saying having having a
[ __ ] boo sponsor and never mention oh
he probably doesn't talk about
alcoholism because of high noon
yeah bro
bro he got destroyed and again dave
porter has like four million i think
followers or something and and stein has
267 and he got ratio
i've never seen it i've never seen it
because nobody is on portnoy side now
nobody
yeah i mean wow
oh i'm looking i'm still looking at it
oh yeah there's a lot like it's
impossible to to really
because it's still it's still happening
but dave portnoy's the guy who was
supposed the guy the guy the guy in the
sixth the guy who was the
the guy the guy with the with the pen
stock scam the the guy the crypto
the guy
mm-hmm uh the the the guy who has to fly
commercial now
yes